herzlich willkommen beim bild leicht
fester
weise ist das dass wir hier auf dieser
karte ist schon wieder ja in
westdeutschland grüne felder sehen bei
der hospitalisierung ist incidents ein
effekt von 30 millionen impf um
die 30 millionen pfund machen hier schon
ein unterschied das ist überhaupt
natürlich und zwar gleich aber die die
infektion hat natürlich auf hoher ebene
stattgefunden die letzten wochen die
zuschauer werden sich erinnern wollen
wir und instituten in einigen
bundesländern von über 500 600.000
gewesen du hast hält eine ein virus
nicht durch irgendwann gibt es dann
keine empfindliche menschen mehr die
denen ja auch auf der kogge die relativ
steil abfällt das hier einfach keine
möglichkeit mehr bestand ist das ihre
sache da laufen konnte also ist eine
kombination und auslaufender im
auslaufenden virus pik und natürlich in
bekämpfungsmaßnahmen unternimmt boostern
was jetzt natürlich an fahrt aufgenommen
jetzt kann man so ein bisschen
durchatmen gerade nach weihnachten gibt
es ein bisschen gute nachrichten
offenbar von der zahlenfront und
gleichzeitig gibt es diese massiven
warnungen vor oregon wie schlimm wird
das denn jetzt kommt diese omikron wand
von der immer die rede ist zerstört
kommt auf jeden fall nicht das ist jetzt
glaube ich nicht mal diskutiert aber was
man vergisst in der berichterstattung
ist dass mit jedem nikon fall wird ja
noch ein delta fall wegfallen also wenn
jetzt 50 60 prozent der fälle
tatsächlich durch einen verursachten
erzählen aber 50 und 60 prozent aller
fälle und delta verursacht ja
offensichtlich schwerere verläufe als
promikon aber hat höchstwahrscheinlich
die geringere übertragungsfähigkeit also
muss man auch die relationen dann
bewahren und schauen sie mal wenn man
sich die zahlen anschaut die die gerade
gezeigt waren liegt
der inzidenz war ja doppelt so hoch wie
der im winter gleichzeitig weil sie
nicht gezeigt haben aber was in diesen
zahlen habe er sicherlich auch ist die
anzahl der personen die auf den
intensivstationen liegen vergleichbar
mit der in der winter werde im letzten
jahr haben doppelt so viele personen die
sind die positiv sind aber viele sind
asymptomatisch rang und die gleiche
anzahl auf den intensivstationen also
das ist zeigt schon wie wie
unterschiedlich die wellen laufen und
ist doch auch ein problem was jetzt sehr
schnell zu lösen ist nämlich der
übergang von der pandemie zu ende - auch
definiert wenn also welche parameter
welche indikatoren wird man sich
anschauen um langsam zur normalität
zurück bekommen in südafrika wird man
jetzt mit kontakt beschränkungen auf und
garantieren ja da sind mineralien unser
land herrschte glauben sie dass das
genauso bei uns kommen wird also das
heißt man muss gar nicht mehr in
quarantäne wenn man es mit einem omikron
fall zu tun gehabt hat also man kann ja
mit ihm fast nichts garantiert auch das
garantiere ich ihnen persönlich das wird
kommen denn irgendwann ist es ja so dass
die normalität einziehen das heißt die
allerhand sind entweder infizierter
immunisiert mehrmals stand dann muss man
die im grenzwertige schwellwert
festlegen wo wir schon normalität
zurückkommen das nur dass man jetzt tun
wir können nicht so lange warten wie
jetzt ist ja doch keine entscheidung
gefallen wie man die serologische
untersuchung der
genesenen auch bewertet ja es gibt
ungefähr 18 12 millionen genesene die
jetzt
denselben status haben müssten sogar
noch besser und schade dass geimpfte
auch das muss man klären wie lang wird
man quasi jeden kontakt geschenke und
aufrecht erhalten welche indikatoren ein
paar habe dann möchte man auch wenn
umsatz zu messen und wann wird man zur
normalität übergehen das alles das kann
man jetzt berechnen würden und auch dann
auch der bevölkerung mit einer das hier
ist ein tolles ziel halten also da muss
ich noch mal nachfragen weil das ja
eigentlich nach der ganz gute nachricht
bei all denen ja immer noch so hohen
zahlen klingt omikron sorgt nach all dem
was wir bisher wissen für im
durchschnitt geringere oder weniger
schlimme verläufe und mit omikron könnte
dann die normalität in unser leben
zurück kommen mehr stört ja also nie
konnte ich die variante die
höchstwahrscheinlich in die interview
passiert danach kommt eine neue das kann
ich ihnen garantieren die wird genauso
wie die promikon und delta und alt
wetter vorher sich langsam an den
menschen anpassen das sehen wir jetzt
schon
übertragungsraten im 2 die
inkubationszeit wird auch langsam kürzer
die hat sich reduziert
findet jetzt denen schon
konkurrierenden in de mission corona
wären da liegt die inkubationszeit bei
zwei bis fünf tagen nähern bei uns die
übertragungsrate steigt auch das ist
eine anpassung an den menschen aber es
geht eigentlich alles in die richtige
richtung richtung n tv aber jetzt ist
natürlich noch winter infektionsdruck
ist sehr hoch ohne frage werden sich
alle die jetzt noch nicht immunisiert
oder infiziert sind auch das virus holen
höchstwahrscheinlich schon in diesem
winter viele natürlich auch erst im
sommer oder nächsten winter aber damit
kann man jetzt dem infektionsdruck
sicherlich reduzieren was man eben
weiter booster die leute die noch nicht
die überhaupt haben in pflanzen auch
noch erreicht und kontakt beschränkung
wird es auch noch weiterhin geben kann
wird zu 99 welle führen aber auch bitte
dieser großen diskrepanz zwischen sehr
vielen thematischen film weniger leuten
auf intensivstationen und die todesfälle
haben sich ja auch jetzt halbiert im
vergleich zum letzten jahr danke an den
virologen klaus stört der uns gute und
schlechte nachricht mitbringt
hochansteckende omikron diese wand diese
welle wird kommen dass es ganz sicher
aber eher garantiert ja soweit er das
kann dass die kontakt beschränkung dann
fallen werden fallen müssen denn sonst
ist das hier alles gar nicht mehr
aufrecht zu erhalten sagt der virologe
klaus stört danke dafür ich bin